mais qu'est ce que c'est aujourd'hui que
le socialisme dans une situation comme
la nôtre dans un pays développé
malcommode il n'y a pas de modèle
il faut donc de l'imagination il faut
réinventer
c'est l'objet de la solution socialiste
que je vous décris aujourd'hui au nom de
notre courant le socialisme c'est
d'abord un combat
regardez d'ailleurs le peu de sécurité
que nous avons aujourd'hui dans la
société française
ces nationalisations qui nous garantisse
contre les dégâts des crises économiques
ou au moins une partie d'entre eux la
sécurité sociale les congés payés la
suppression des zones de salaire même
que de longues queues de dures grève
il a fallu pour les imposer et cela
continuera
c'est partout et toujours la lutte qui
arrachent et la loi légalise après voilà
pourquoi et comment le socialisme et
incombent